we're told rava is researching an
electric car she finds this graph which
shows how much range measured in
kilometers the car gains based on
charging time
all right and they say first fill in the
missing values in the table below and if
you are so inspired pause this video and
see if you can have a go at that as well
all right well they give us a few points
and i'm assuming these are points on a
line and we can see when the charging
time is 15 minutes the range is 180 so
we can see when the charging time is 15
minutes the range is 180. we can see
when the charging time is 30 minutes the
range is
360 kilometers so i could write that
there
and then we see when the charging time
is 45 minutes the range is
540. kilometers
so that's all
nice but then they give us a few other
points here they say what happens when
we are at t equals 10 or t equals one
which aren't easy to pick out here but
this is where it might be useful if we
assume that this is a line what is the
relationship between these
so let's see to go from 15 to 180 it
looks like you're multiplying by 12. to
go from 30 to 360 it looks like we're
multiplying by 12 to go from 45 to 540
it looks like we are multiplying by 12.
so assuming k is just going to be 12
times t we know that when t equals 1
k is 12 and when t equals 10 10 times 12
is 120.
all right now the second part they say
write an equation rava can use to find
out how much charging time t
it takes to gain any number of
kilometers in range k all right well we
already established a relationship we
said that k
is equal to 12
times whatever t is that's what we just
established in this table up here but
that's not what they want they want to
find out how much charging time t
it takes to gain any number of
kilometers in range k so what we need to
do here is solve for t
so let's divide both sides by 12
to just have a t by itself on the right
hand side
and we are going to left be left with t
is equal to k over 12.
t is equal to k over 12. and notice you
could put any number of kilometers of
range in here and you're essentially
just going to divide it by 12 and that
will give you how much charging time and
i guess this would assume an infinitely
large battery which we know doesn't
exist but for the sake of this problem
here we have it here is the equation
rava can use